this is that painful point in every
dolphin season usually around
mid-november
when all hope is lost and I turn to the
NFL's official odds maker eat deputy 445
yo Dan yo what the it is my things
are having me on dog see the thing is
about this whole Super Bowl bullshitting
how do team's look midseason orders ever
let's keep it real here
mine we already know who's gonna win the
Super Bowl it's gonna be
New England yeah they
might give you a smoke screen
with New England and the Rams and New
England and New Orleans
but then New England's going to win the
Superbowl and that's my flock in a week
the Patriots that fluke 16 year run is
over there goes to Erick Hernandez is
gonna curse that franchise